I actually talked about this guy  yesterday and I brought up Jonathan  turley's article on him and he called  them the Kevin Bacon of the Russian  collusion Scandal the the story here is  just absolutely bewildering especially  when you look into the greater details  this guy was fired from the FBI for  leaking information on the Trump  Administration this guy was behind a lot  of the major warrants that were spying  on the Donald Trump campaign this guy  then was working with Vijaya Gotti  one-on-one when it came to censoring  people in our political landscape  predominant people who supported the  Trump Administration this guy's  connected to the clintons he's connected  to James Comey he's connected to almost  virtually everyone in the political  sphere and Elon Musk didn't even know he  was working at Twitter deciding what  kind of documents Barry Weiss and Matt  taibi were getting what that's how does  that make sense it does it does that  make sense to you